ملايين الاطفال بحاجه لدعم انسانيه عاجل
في كل من سوريا وتركيا وفق اليونيسف في
عقاب زلزال مدمر تصف المنظمه تاثيره على
الاطفال في المنطقه واسرهم بالكارسي ولم
تحدد اليونيسف عدد ضحايا الزلزال من
الاطفال ولكنها تتوقع ان يبلغ بضعه الف
اما الناجونه منهم فترجح احصائيات المنظمه
تاثر اربعه ملايين ونصف المليون طفل
بالزلزال في تركيا بينما بلغ عدد الاطفال
المتاثرين من الزلزال في سوريا مليونين
ونصف المليون الوضع الصعب على الارض يتطلب
دعما يشمل بالخصوص المياه الصالحه للشرب
والصرف الصحي والغذاء والامدادات الصحيه
والدعم النفسي للاطفال على المدى الطويل
تصف اليونيسف فاحتياجات المتضررين
بالهائله والتحديات بالكثيره والمعقده في
ظل تضرر الطرق الرئيسيه والبنيه التحتيه
الى جانب سوء الاحوال الجويه